to some breaking news now breaking
certainly in the last hour and Benjamin
Netanyahu has won the Israeli election
after the Prime Minister yeah lapid
conceded defeat Sky's Aleister bunkel
joins us now from Jerusalem good evening
Aleister well Benjamin Netanyahu is
certainly a political survivor he's back
he's back indeed the votes are still
being counted the last votes but yala P
the outgoing prime minister has clearly
concluded that almost 48 hours after the
poll closed it is a done deal it's a Fed
complete he's lost Benin Netanyahu has
won and it will mean that Israel's
longest serving prime minister Netanyahu
served for 15 out of the last 26 years
will become Prime Minister again for the
sixth time
having said that in many respects the
hard work begins now for benign
Netanyahu he needs to form a coalition
and forming a Coalition in Israeli
politics is no easy task you'll need at
least three other parties to come on
board with him they will all want their
pound of Flesh they will all have their
demands of him and he'll need to keep
them on side if a single one of them
bolts then he might be in trouble but he
is now in a position of power once again
he is
whether he's liked or loathed by the
Israeli public and a remarkable
politician he has been campaigning in
opposition he clearly felt wounded that
he was put into opposition by the
Coalition party that's been governing
for the last 16 months or so a coalition
that only came together with a load of
disparate parties uh really with one
thing in common that was the dislike of
Netanyahu but Israel has voted for the
fifth time in four years and finally
they have been decisive they want
Benjamin Netanyahu to be the next prime
minister it's now we see whether or not
he can form that Coalition and what the
makeup of it is because the one other
factor that came out of this election
was the far the rise of the far right
and that is concerning a lot of people
both here in the West Bank and around
the world as well will the likes of
itamar bengavir and nationalist
extremist politician get a major job in
netanyahu's Coalition I noticed tonight
that the U.S ambassador to Israel has
already spoke to Netanyahu and
congratulated him will Biden be so quick
we understand the White House has also
got concerns about the makeup of this
coalition government but Netanyahu once
again an extraordinary politician surely
one of the most successful politicians
in global democracy is yet again heading
to become the prime minister of Israel
okay uh Alistair thank you very much
indeed